hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys I'm
Brandi price you make me sound like age
transgender well I got my girl yeah boys
didn't go to my eyes I'm ready price
yeah this is my impression of right
we're gonna watch the trailer today
foreverly I saw I saw the red band
trailer when she stopped looking I saw
the red band trailer for this it looked
cool it looked okay there are times
where it looked really good at a time
drowsily yeah this is a regular green
band trailer so we won't get all the
goodies but it's rated R for strong
bloody violence torture nudity sexual
images and language [ __ ] and stars salma
hayek oh yeah that's why it's ready to
talk cuz she is pretty boobies yeah
boobies boobies Bobby Bobby I cancer
your phone
you betrayed me it will die in that room
to like my men are already there what's
your good to do I have a plan mom you
need to see me so I can give you enough
money for you to start a new life you're
not going to make it
every week
I assume go down without a fight
you know guns dad wanted a boy
I know you haven't seen the red band
trailer yeah but if they were able to
combine this with the awesome cuz the
movie looks from the red band trailer
and look it's like very violent over the
top but it like delivers on the goods
but because this is a green band trailer
you can't necessarily get that stuff but
I wish they combined kind of that
trailer because the tone of this one
combined with awesome looking violence I
want to see this movie a lot now because
I also saw the red band trailer but the
red band trailer loan did it make me
just want to see the film oh it's a
combination of two so I'm seeing good
job movie marketing yeah got it why do
you know what you're doing yeah but no
it's essentially kill bill meets die
hard that's what I was thinking about
well yeah because there's a lot of
comedic elements to it yeah it's kill
bill with the over-the-top bunch of a
female or male in kill bill it's like
uma Thurman and then a bunch of you know
hot ass [ __ ] and then [ __ ] bill
and now it's seven now it's the Salma
Hayek some [ __ ] and this one asian
dude like with the sword and they reveal
who he is the whole time they're like
this is a mystery of who I like Charlie
and Charlie's Angels yeah and then they
show who it is in the trick wait I'm not
supposed to know who ya ruins the
surprise I think that it's really cool
how it it has a lot of the comedic
elements of it I'd like those over the
top films that really commit to it and
know how to do it right with life like
what's in cities should have been yeah
our sin city to [ __ ] man same problem i
was in city to the same probably have a
machete kills yes machete had this
really over-the-top very violent vibe
but i have life to it as opposed to the
sequel which was like it felt empty I
was like all that shit's in front of me
but I don't feel life in this exactly
I'm hoping that this movie does not do
that words like a bunch of cool images
but I don't feel any life in it you're
not making me feel ya i'm in the feels I
want to be like in that theater being
like that's a [ __ ] badass oh [ __ ]
yeah dude oh look at that us you did say
that
did say Eddie she has a great ass for
like what is for she has to be four tees
in Hollywood years that's like 75 so she
looks great for 75 years old she's like
I think she is in her 40's actually I
don't know she hasn't kids she got
really big when she had kids because
she's tiny mm-hmm she's like five feet
she's got that body bag she looks good
she doesn't look good and she looks like
a batter being badass the fact that
Salma Hayek is back in a badass role
because she came onto the scene with
Desperados is had to be a badass check
right and her accident so damn cute I
know that's what's cool about it cuz I'm
like she's cool intimidating but damn is
she a door oh yeah because you can't
help but hear the sweetness in her voice
she talks somaya looks badass yes from
the red band trailer combined with this
it looks funny it looks funny and it
looks over the top and energetic those
are just fun rated R flicks yeah the
special effects are a little man I would
still like to know what the hell's going
on though they're trying to kill her I
know but why cuz she stole money oh yeah
that's right they made that pretty clear
in the trailer yeah anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you should
subscribe to the real rejects randy has
a channel to does a lot of independent
movie reviews check that [ __ ] out and
shut up and ratio now alexander wit ham
wit with him with him widom hey Ryan
it's me again I remember can you give my
friend Marco Ramirez and I shout out he
and I laugh at your vids thanks PS the D
is silent in your name Alexander yeah
thanks for all the facts my friend why
is it Marco Polo [ __ ] commenting on
the channel and the Facebook and said
why don't you wise why are you talking
for him are you like his [ __ ] is that
it Alexander are you a Marco like
[ __ ] but you're the [ __ ] and the
relationship maybe he's just a nice
person and a nice friend no no that
doesn't exist at all in life kindness
yeah that's true there are a lot of mean
ass people in the world
there are well the devil's real Sofia
not streets but Alexander and Marco okay
Margo seemed like nice guy Marco you
seem like a great guy I love to give you
a shout out Marco Ramirez shout out
completely Isaiah oh he's a black guy I
like my black friends because it makes
me look cool to have black friends he
[ __ ] that's me sulting Isaiah kamek
byram give me a shout out you saying i
am sorry [ __ ] give me a shout out you
sexy beast and by the way i have a
youtube channel it's qinghai dog
everyone one of my best black friends
has a channel called King I dog go
subscribe to this channel right now open
out my brother what is wrong with ya try
to make sure i'm cool with the black
community meet one comment on Star Wars
video and everyone's like is you racist